hello everyone thanks for coming to my
talk I know it can I have some stiff
competition with the matplotlib talk so
I appreciate you coming out and seeing
me today what I'm going to talk about is
how me and my company max points along
with all my great colleagues have
actually used by data and put it into
production and got it into the hands of
our users so now just to introduce
myself once again you know Josh house
have been at max point for three and a
half years I'm a senior manager they're
still pretty hands-on though working on
a variety problems from geo spatial
analytics to traditional kind of machine
learning prediction classification
problems causal inference those types of
things this is my company max point you
know we're sponsor here I'm sure you
probably accidentally stumbled into a
couple of our other talks today what max
point does actually is where a marketing
technology company we help our brands
large retailers advertising agencies be
smarter about how they spend their
marketing dollars but you guys probably
really don't care about that what you
care about and what I think makes us
interesting for this crowd is that we
have we have large data sets and
interesting data sets we're HDFS to do
shop and we have hundreds of terabytes
of data from everything from how we did
an RGB space for for delivering ads to
geospatial datasets again to
point-of-sale data and we have
interesting problems and we use the PI
data stack to solve them so we're trying
to predict who will respond to an
advertisement online how do people move
about physical space and does that tell
us something interesting are there
things about the data that we collect
that tell our customers what's more what
how they should better spend their money
so I'll talk a little bit about our
software ecosystem and kind of frame
what production actually means and what
kind of just constraints were working
with when we're talking about production
but the key thing is that you know we
have kind of two main stakeholders in
our product software stack first is the
data science team and our data science
team does a variety of things we do kind
of data analytics and data analysis
to help guide the business we do methods
research but we also actually implement
our our ideas in software that lives in
production and we do that largely in
Python and using the PI data tools a
couple of examples here you know we're
using classifiers to predict the
effectiveness of advertising or do topic
models on web content we're building
geospatial models and in many more
examples the other people that are
putting code into production next point
is our traditional software engineering
group and this this group is really
responsible for all other aspects of the
software including system health and
performance all the non-functional
requirements that people that are in the
day of data science domain just don't
care about the call till ities
availability reproducibility
accessibility those type of things
logging monitoring system health and
they do many more things as well but we
come at the problems from very different
perspectives we're very much focused on
how do we produce analytical pieces and
compare that to how does this largely
fit into a bigger system so we have kind
of these these two groups who are you
know largely thinking about different
things and approaching software
development from different worldviews
and we largely have different software
structures on top of it I have a beard
so the data science guy is the bearded
guy so we're largely uh using Python
although we will use our and I think
we've even toyed a little bit with Julia
and some other languages as well but
basically we're using the tools that
make us most productive doing data
science challenges and we largely are
not thinking about the other pieces of
the puzzle that the software engineering
group is carrying most of their time
about on the other side our engineer
group you know is largely working in the
JVM and that includes both Java as well
as kind of a recent plunge into Scala we
have some closure in our code base we
have C++ on our high-speed systems
our front-end systems are in C sharp
sharp C sharp and there's really
actually very little overlap
traditionally in types of tools and
approaches we've taken to how we
implement software and so this is
actually you know causing causes some
problems when you want to help put
people help click code into production
you kind of have a couple different
options and they all have pretty big
trade-offs because what we really want
is we want to be able to adapt quickly
and put things in to get things to
market quickly we want to make sure that
we keep both sides happy we want
analytics to be able to feel like
they're contributing we want software
engineering to to feel like the systems
in a good state they don't have to be
called at three o'clock in the morning
because something breaks and we still
want to make sure we have all these non
functional requirements built in and
most importantly I think we really want
to make sure we minimize the
opportunities where we have to write
rewrite code because the option where we
implement an algorithm and hand it off
to someone else to implement in Java or
closure one is pretty inefficient and it
hurts that time to market but also is
very very difficult in some
circumstances you know SK learn for
example is a fast-moving evolving
library that has a lot of machine
learning algorithms finding a sister
library in Java that implements the same
things is just it's impossible actually
and so having being able to kind of make
sure we're not having to translate these
types of things writing new custom code
and not relying on the community is
something that we really want to avoid
so I'll talk about kind of two big
workloads that we're going to talk about
today in terms of how we've tried to
bridge that gap the first one is just
interactive workload these are kind of
our real real ish time processes that
require interaction with an end user and
so you can imagine someone is sitting in
front of their computer they are asking
for data likely parametrized by some
settings and they're expecting responses
back in nearish real time and so how
we've approached this at max point is by
building but i'll just call analytics
microservices and micro services is
pretty kind of popular concept in
software engineering but basically what
it means is we're going to be would
prefer to build a lot of small services
with very compact api's rather than one
monolith service that requires a lot of
maintenance and difficulty making
changes in releases and so how we've
done this both trying to preserve the
Java and the non-functional ward for
software engineering and all the access
to all the PI data goodies that our data
scientists like is we've kind of used
this wrapper approach twine between our
our service layers so we implemented it
with kind of with Apache thrift which
I'll talk a little bit more in a second
but it's basically providing the the RPC
calls between the Python layer and the
Java layer and what this really is
allowed us to do is we can put all those
non-functional requirements that our
data scientists don't care about hide
them up in the Java layer and the
analytics the things that we're doing in
Python is really isolated exclusively to
the things that our data scientists care
about it also really it makes it much
easier for us to reuse the logic that
our engineering counterparts have
implemented you know other services that
we have within the organization are all
written in Java and so they can pull
those things in and support analytical
products with all the non-functional
requirements even though that all the
core logic is implemented in Python um
so this is a very simplistic version but
basically what happens is we have this
this Java layer that is basically
calling out to the PI data later through
Apache thrift and how we've kind of made
this work is we actually have a pool of
processes that are running our Python
code the Java layer is doing all the
kind of queue management making sure
that we're load balancing across these
Python processes and ultimately
providing the public interface to all
our clients so nothing knows about the
the private pool that is implementing
the Python stack
outside of this public service that's
been made public to the rest of the the
service-oriented architecture that we
have in house out of curiosity how many
people are familiar with Apache thrift
just so you get a sense so the audience
is people used it or seen it okay a
smattering um so you know basically what
Apache thrift is is is this remote
procedure call language and and it is a
language in that it has its own dsl and
the dsl basically allows you to define
your your their service in thrift and it
will handle all the translations and
marshalling to various libraries that
need to use it so you would end up
defining your service and this is an
example just from thrift documentation
where you actually define your service
in this this dsl as a dot thrift file
you're finding everything from your name
spaces to custom and news to struck sand
complex data types exceptions in this
thrift file ultimately implementing your
high level services and the methods that
they're going to support and then what
happens you run a tool which is thrift
gin and you tell it which bindings you
actually want to produce so this is
pretty cool in a lot of ways although
there is some some problems in that
you're you're dealing with kind of the
lowest common denominator and a lot of
the things that you have here any kind
of nice abstractions that you may have
in Python if they're not implemented in
Java well we're kind of in some trouble
from thriss perspective so you kind of
ties your hands a little bit in that
you're kind of working with these trucks
and these primitive types but it
actually does a lot of the marshaling I
think this is a pretty interesting
approach especially if you're
considering the other option which
commonly used is implementing rest
services rest services you still have to
work you have to worry about all the
marshaling translating of the data
thrift actually takes care of a lot of
this stuff for you so when you run this
this thrift gin it actually
not the stubs and produce produces out
both a service layer and a client layer
to be able to talk back and forth
through these things and so in this
example this is the the server layer
which is basically you know implementing
these methods there's a lot of code
that's not shown here and all these
thrift transports shared key types that
kind of handles all the marshalling back
and forth and the getting it you know
across the wire to the other services
but it gives you these nice templates
for which you can then implement and in
any of these methods you can you know
start importing your numpy or pandas
your SK learn to be able to implement
similarly it also this little small but
I think it shows the purpose which is it
also implements your service code are
your client code excuse me which is how
would you actually connect to this
service and you know so the idea is that
you know its handling the protocols the
transport layer is the sockets layers
for you and you generate this in both
Python and Java and these layers can
talk to each other so we're kind of some
lessons learned from from this this
approach I think there's some really
kind of cool things about doing doing
your interactive wear clothes in this
manner one it really helped us separate
the the pieces of the logic between
engineering and the data science
community we can have people that are
focused on data science and people that
are focused at engineering and they're
able to actually work in parallel a lot
more effectively it also as I mentioned
allowed us to share more work and have
kind of some reproducible code we can
keep all our core logic for the
non-functional requirements in the Java
world we don't have to move things over
to Python to have Python services and
kind of try to keep those things in sync
would have been a nightmare but there
are some negative things it's also often
very hard to actually define what this
analytic Mike microservice is and
there's what what I'll call analytic
scope creep around how much work the
Python Python layer should actually be
doing a good example would be just data
access should that be done by the Java
service that should be done by the
Python service other the
the tough decisions you have to make
when you're doing this model and still
you're actually having to do some
implementation in both places even if it
is doing this thin shim layer
communicating back and forth it is kind
of a still a double implementation layer
and and that's in that stinks right and
and thrift is easier it's definitely
easier than if you were trying to do
this yourself but it isn't trivial nor
easy you do have to start to learn this
other thrift spec language although not
complicated is still some cognitive load
that you're taking on when you're
talking about your service you have to
think a little bit more about how you
structure your return results because
you're using these trucks and these
these other kind of more easily
translatable data structures that talk
across code and so it's not it's not
simple and trivial but it actually
allows us to do a lot of things so the
next part i'll talk about batch
workloads which is where most of our
effort is actually spent and how do we
are using python there so kind of the
basic approach here we can take is we
just process do everything that we're
going to do in terms of using numpy
pandas and just processing it locally
where you use a single machine will
install our kind of environments there
any data that's requiring access to our
large data well sample we'll pick some
smaller amount of data pull it down to
this machine crunch on it push it back
up to our cluster that that works
reasonably well especially because we
can stay in the Python world for certain
workloads so what I'm showing here on
this slide is actually Ibis ibis is a
project that Cloudera is working on that
works with their real-time sequel engine
Impala and ibis allows you to write
things that looks a lot like pandas and
what will happen is it basically
compiles this these instructions into
the sequel query that you would see here
that would be executed on the cluster so
you actually get some remote capability
still written in Python can pull it back
local
the working in pandas the switching
costs are relatively small and you know
the ibis the main author of ibis is Wes
McKinney so he does try to borrow a lot
of the concepts around brown pandas and
so you'll see a lot of the same
structures it's it's nice in that you're
not switching between writing these big
long sequel strings in your code which
are hard to debug hard to change hard to
parameterize you're actually writing
code that looks like the types of code
that you're running before but the
problem is when you actually can't do
something locally and you're doing
research and all of sudden oh that the
thing that I think would scale well and
I can run on one's machine actually
can't and so what happens now is we have
to get someone to rewrite it and so
we've invested some effort and trying to
make that easier and parameterizing
models and allow to hand off models
written in sk learn to implementing
models that are actually implemented
enclosure for Casca log running on
hadoop but that is really kind of quite
inefficient it slows our time to market
it makes things a little bit more
difficult so you know what have we
learned from kind of doing this local
local approach you know the big thing is
that it's it's there's some really nice
features on you're going from an
environment where you're very familiar
in your research spec when you're
writing pandas you're working on a
notebook you're pulling data down you're
doing your analysis to make it into a
production job you basically are just
scheduling that script to run
parametrized by some I whatever your
model maybe it's a timestamp and um and
that's pretty much it you don't not
doing this kind of big conversion to go
from production and that speeds up some
cycles but the idea between working on a
big data company is the one thing you
should learn is that the it's really bad
to bring your data to your your code
your data is big gigabytes terabytes
your code is small kilobytes megabytes
so you much rather move your data your
code to your data than vice versa and
that's what we're doing in these local
local environments it also you know
really actually requires you to
some pretty beefy hardware and when you
have beefy hardware it actually requires
you to share resources in which causes
its own its own problems and I think you
can get a little sloppy in your project
dependencies when you're doing this if
you're going quickly from development to
production how do you make sure you have
the right version the pandas how do you
handle all these packaging is not
trivial so you know the next thing is
well how can we do this still writing
Python and bring the code to the data
and one of the things we've tried it at
max point in limited amounts is actually
streaming MapReduce and what that does
is it allows us to actually bring our
Python packages to the cluster you how
you implement as you basically write a
Python script that either works on the
map or side or the reduced side of the
job and the Java layer that runs
MapReduce is calling out to these these
scripts and so basically how it works is
this is you have a dupe in the Java
layer that's doing kind of input reading
your input off your HDFS cluster in the
map stream it's calling out through
standard and standard out piping that
back through the Java layer who takes it
to the reduced strain handles all your
shuffling back through standard in
standard out to your reduced layer which
is in Python back into the Java layer
out to your output layer and so if the
data flows like that as you can tell
you're working in through standard and
standard out and actually you as the
developer is writing into standard in
and standard out and so this is what
your code ends up looking right right
for line and standard in do something
with this nasty line of text that works
ok if you're working with something like
you know cscs vs um you want to use some
other type of data structure parquet
things start to kind of break down there
so now this is very low level MapReduce
programming at this point and largely
we've moved past this I think as as a
community in the pig data space as well
as at a company at max point this is how
typically you'd have to do it and you'd
basically just be calling out through
Hadoop um with these mappers and these
reducers written written in Python
so you know what are kind of the lessons
you know one it's really opens you up
even though it's more painful it really
opens you up to being able to do more
interesting things because you're not no
longer constrained to the RAM or the
resources that you have in a single
machine you can now run bigger nastier
models and it kind of fits well it's a
supported part of the MapReduce
ecosystem the streaming API is one of
the api's of MapReduce so you're
actually using betted tools although it
does feel a little ugly but again you're
running into the packaging problem
around how do you get your code to all
the nodes on the cluster now that's a
challenge and you having to write code
that's relying on the low level standard
in standard out interfaces which again I
would say is not it's not fun so you
know enter apache spark we've made a big
push over the past year to move to
apache spark for our processing
pipelines and for those you are not
familiar with patchy spark basically
it's this big compute platform came out
of some work at the amp lab at Cal
Berkeley but what's nice about it form
our workloads is that actually has
multiple AP is supported at a pretty
high level and as foundational to the
packages itself which includes a java
scala python and even our and so what
this allows us to do and i'm sorry one
other thing it also exposes machine
learning libraries exclusively in the
package as well with this ml spark and
mel and mi lib and so what this really
allows us to do is to have actually one
platform to do both our engineering
pipelining tasks as well as the model
fitting metal prediction data analytics
tasks using all the same tools it's nice
in that has a lot of kind of high-level
built-in impurity vande declarative
abstractions so analysts who prefer to
write sequel can write sequel you can do
the things like the ibis pandas type
some text as well and everything won't
be able to execute on the cluster um it
also has spark ml which is provides
some high level models for doing machine
learning that have been optimized for
running on the cluster which is which is
important so if you guys haven't seen
spark ml this is basically what it looks
like this is using the Python interface
again there's Scala and Java interfaces
as well the nice thing is that for
someone who's a Python user a lot of the
syntax actually should feel pretty
familiar to you there's concepts like
these these transforms there's a
concepts of the models y'all implement
the same API is they have the you know
the pipeline API similar to SK learn and
so you're actually working in Python
although your work you know operating on
the cluster and the the spark is
handling obviously getting all the jars
and all the necessary source code to all
the nodes of the cluster so that's
pretty cool and I think it's really
interesting in that you now fit models
on all your data you can predict on all
your data um but you know again this is
very very nice but the problem is is
that you're pretty you're still reliant
on Pais Park and what's available in
pais park and there really is less
capability in some subtle differences
between that and what we use in the
numpy world are pandas world or sk
learnable it's a slightly different
dialect which can be a little bit
frustrating because you are doing a
little bit of context switching but
still it's not so bad comparing running
through switching from Java to Python
for example but the big data
abstractions are very useful you're
you're working at you're able to be able
to do kind of functional programming on
the big data using kind of things like
map partitions reduced by Keys group by
keys which are very powerful and again
you're now bringing your code to the
data which just makes things much more
scalable so you know as we look through
this we said there's some really great
things well how do we actually combined
kind of pie spark and the PI data
platform and there's kind of some nice
things about PI spark is that you can
actually write
closures and anonymous functions and so
what we want to do is specifically try
to build workloads that take advantage
of using spark and pie spark for all the
high level data manipulation getting
data in the right format doing all the
shuffling on disk and then actually
running our models through the PI data
stack and this works particularly well
for us in that a lot of our models
fitting and predicting are actually
highly paralyzed abul in that we're
normally only fitting and predicting on
a subset of our data so we can shuffle
all the data around get it on the right
places and run multiple instances of the
same model on little subsets of the data
so this works pretty well and we've
built some tools and we've opens or some
tools I'll talk about in a second around
helping us distribute Conda environments
more effectively through yarn and
getting it on the cluster so so here is
a very kind of simple example so we're
in writing pi spark here and what we
have is we have a method predict and
what that method predict takes is an
array which is a features and actually
what would be a fitted SK learned model
and what this will do is will use this
predict method will curry it with a pre
fitted model will tell the return type
and create a user-defined function in
spark and what that allows us to do is
then use the spark data frames the spark
abstractions that they built and
actually run our model using those
abstractions although it is a scalar
model implemented so that that's pretty
powerful right now now we have all the
PI data in a way that we can use within
spark distributed on a cluster and
everything is written in Python no
translation link translating between
languages no requiring indigent rewrites
no sacrificing capabilities we have kind
of the best of both worlds in this
example so how do we do it this is a
kind of a basic diagram taken from this
spark documentation around House spark
works
but basically you have a driver program
that kind of controls spark context you
have the cluster manager and you have
your worker nodes where all the work
does this happens so the driver program
is basically pushing out work to the the
workers pushing out code making sure the
environments are ready the cluster
manager is making sure that resources
are using correctly and the spark
context is kind of managing across this
work so how do we actually do it well
basically we're using yarn and Conda
we're packaging up our environments in a
basically the environment ya moul
specification that kind of uses and we
distribute those through yarn and we
have some custom code that basically
will build those environments on the
workers on demand that is a pretty big
big change because otherwise the
alternative is you have DevOps you have
someone in your cluster team oh maybe I
don't know if they do maybe they're
running around with the USB EOC but
they're there they're actually
responsible for having to put those
applicate those environments on the on
the cluster this gives us the
opportunity to find what are the
environments that we care about I'm
doing some new geospatial work well I
can import I can bring in a geospatial
library to find my environment and
actually get that out on our cluster to
run our job against that's pretty cool
and so we've kind of recently open
sourced a project called spy lon and the
project does a lot of different things
but it makes the interaction between
Scotland and Python a little bit easier
because spark is written in Scala but it
also handles this distribute
distribution of different kind of
environments through yarn it's
relatively new project I think just a
few months old we just will open sourced
it so you can feel free to check it out
or contribute but it's really going to
be it's part of our data platform now
and we pulled this part out of the
toolkit to basically give it back to the
community so so lessons learned again we
kind of right now we get all the
advantages of this using pi spark and
also now have access to the PI data task
with spy on we now can actually just
tribute custom environments to the
cluster through yarn relatively easily
the one downside though is that it still
does require kind of some low-level
knowledge of how spark works so we're
not completely free of just not having
to think about spark and big data we're
interacting with a lower level API
within spark typically no resilient
distributed data sets for our dd's when
we're doing these these types of
modeling but still it's much easier than
anything else that it possible some
final thoughts I think now one thing I
didn't talk about today that i think is
another use case which is pretty
interesting which is reporting and how
do you actually produce reports which is
another piece of our work I think it's
really exciting as you look around the
community attend these talks there's a
lot of interesting opportunities to
change how we actually do reporting as
well and we're still trying to figure
that out but you look at the things that
the the jabber dashboard communities
starting into that tutorial look at the
bouquet and what's available in those
bouquet dashboards those are really cool
and I think it's also just extending how
we can get the data in our code in the
hands of our users with the smallest
number of hurdles possible and that's
that's really exciting um so with that I
think I'm done with my 30 minutes and
open up for questions Thank You Josh we
have 10 minutes for questions so there
we go um I was interested you said it's
bad to bring your data to the code I
didn't quite get what you meant by that
can you explain that a little more sure
um so when we're talking about hadoop
world and what we do at max point is we
have all our data on a distributed
cluster and in in the data center spread
across multiple machines in this data
can literally is hundreds of terabytes
and so if you're running code that
requires you to pull down tens 20
terabytes of data that takes a lot of
time
the flip side is you take your source
code which is 10 or you know tens or
twenties hundreds of kilobytes and
taking that to the data that's much more
efficient not to mention all the
shuffling and in those type of things of
reading from different machines it's
just much easier much more efficient to
bring the small small data to which is
the code to the big data which is living
on your cluster then vice versa sign up
I understand this a big performance hit
when you send Python out to the cluster
because it's gotta spin up Python
workers it's got to serialize
deserialize all the data back and forth
to those worker threads um so I've been
trying to avoid that can you speak to
that a little bit I think you're exactly
exactly right I mean other remote
procedure call this translation and
things that I was talking about when we
were doing the interactive work clothes
for doing through thrift that still is
happening in this in the PI spark world
you know spark is natively on the JVM
and its handling this kind of threw some
pickling magic getting your code
everywhere and you're paying a penalty
for doing it I mean the question really
is and you know maybe it's always for
kind of optimization is what do you want
to optimize are you optimizing developer
time or computer time and I think what
this allows you to do though still is
make that a conscious decision and
decide when you want to move from caring
about your developer time to caring
about your computer time the nice thing
about the PI spark spark Trant spark
ecosystem is that Scala is actually
relatively close to the pipe i spark
syntax and so migrating things from PI
spark exclusively to scala spark isn't a
huge lift obviously it requires people
to learn new things which yeah as i may
be implied but translation translation
your PI spark jobs to scala spark isn't
as awful
I mean devs would probably say this
rewrite is still the worst but not the
worst I've ever seen but it we can't
really it's harder to solve that with
with combining spark in the PI data
stack though when you move to spell
follow-up question so I found that the
SK learn library is far superior dove
the spark machine learning is that what
the primary drivers of this effort to
spy on thing it's a key piece I mean
it's hard to write big data machine
learning algorithms that kind of can
paralyze across machines and so I think
SK learn can move a lot faster frankly
and it's been around more as so it is a
big base I mean it also is enabled by
the fact that we do have these kind of
parallelizable workloads that actually
don't require us to read all our data in
simultaneously and fit models but yeah
we want to be able to use sk learn
because it has a lot more capabilities
than just spark a mental block out the
box
a quick question I work in a in a
microsoft.net shop how much of this is
portable over to a Microsoft echo system
I think well especially the interactive
workloads I can say for sure is I mean I
i well I shouldn't say for sure I very
pretty sure that the thrift binding
support things like C sharp and so you
know that part would work basically the
same um yeah I don't know if anyone has
any kind of large-scale Microsoft spark
implementation so that's a little bit
outside of what I understand but I think
from the interactive workloads the model
still face what is Python it's good
question on the spot from the youngest
member oh yeah so python is this magical
thing that allows you to be able to do
so much more than you ever really
realized was possible just by typing on
your computer I don't really understand
all that much about how thrift works but
I can you give me some idea of like what
what kind of throughput can you use
thrift for is like this high volume and
does it have any kind of fault tolerance
and or handling yeah I mean you are it's
definitely not a high-throughput type
interface there you know you you are
where you are kind of offering and
working these different protocols and
how you transfer it it's definitely not
really designed for high throughput or
clothes I don't really think there's any
fault tolerance those type of things as
well it's most mostly for smaller data
for works now
I guess this is more of a suggestion /
plug for something sure but if you're
using thrift the I saw that you guys
were using the official thrift Apache
thrifting elimination there's a library
called thrift buy that is a pure python
thrifty movement H implementation and
it's actually much much easier to use
from Python and you can actually import
your thrift files like so that's bec you
have you can do like import whatever dot
thrift and it will make a magic python
module for you on the fly that's come on
so I would recommend that that's cool
any downsides to that it's very slightly
slower than the Apache implementation
but it uses psyphon so it's like you
know very very slight it's cool i'll
check it out yeah um with regards to the
I guess you called it the micro analytic
services I was curious about the debug
experience like if there's bugs it seems
like you'd need a combination of skills
on both the engineering and the data
science side and so could you comment a
little bit about that experience yeah
you're right um and I guess I probably
glossed over it a little bit in that you
know I you still have to do some of the
non-functional requirements in your
Python code in these micro services you
know logging for example handling kind
of error messages and passing them back
through so you do still have to think a
little bit about some of those things
and it does require a mix of skill sets
when someone's work interacting with
your service and something goes wrong I
think it's I think it's worth it but
there is there's not it's not a perfect
solution in that regard
is a robust Sarah handling and the
thrift layer itself and good error codes
to look at you actually have to build
your own exceptions there's an
exceptions I guess instructor and thrift
but you're basically constructing your
own exceptions here they have some base
ones like no transport exceptions those
type of things but you're any custom
application code that you want to be
able to handle air handling on you're
building your own custom exceptions all
right and with that let's night Josh